all right what's this 911 conspiracy
Aaron Rodgers uh at the point right now
he's a quarterback for the Packers okay
but free agency just started today so
I'm hoping this isn't going to be
spoiled has he signed somewhere else
oh okay I thought you're pulling oh yes
okay
um so the free agency is happening today
and if he goes to the Jets this is going
to be you know rotten milk anyways why
because he's on the Packers right now
but the Packers I believe don't like him
very much because he keeps creating all
this drama for the media and all this
[__] but it's kind of funny that if he
does go to the New York Jets the media
in New York is [__] like even worse
like the questions are like at least for
an example for like a New York Outlet
would be like did you smoke weed this
morning Aaron Rodgers and he would be
like that's not news for you and then
the headline would read like uh Aaron
Rodgers possibly smoked weed this
morning
come on bro so he grew up in the in like
Berkeley area he went to Berkeley he
went to Butte College like way up there
like very drug you know kind of vibe for
Aaron Rodgers this earthy dude and the
way that he's going about free agency
he's dead Ayahuasca to figure out if he
wanted to be a free or if you continue
playing or figure out if you wanted to
play for the Jets or the pack workers
and already like the Packers are like
dude we're like we're so [__] sick of
you bro like you're doing like drugs and
he's doing a dark Retreat did you see
that yeah yeah yeah I heard about that
so he went solo for at least I think it
was like three to five days just in a
dark room it was just Bed Bath and
Beyond just kidding and what thanks
again
I feel like Cody
this was the dark room Retreat
um it was just very solo and there was a
guy that actually did like a YouTube
video like just testing it out and he
was like bumping into [__] and like he
took a 13 out oh this is him he did a
third yeah oh nice he did a 13-hour nap
like he had no idea what time was when
he woke up he just like was tired from
the drive out to like wherever this was
and it's like pitch black yeah pitch
black and so Aaron Rodgers did this to
try and figure out if he wanted to
either retire or continue playing or go
to like another team and [__] like that
so like the Packers are either just like
completely sick of this dude or like are
just wanting him to just shut the [__]
up and play football basically but the
911 conspiracy is in the quarterback
room he would like ask players like just
straight up like DeSean Kaiser did you
do 911
they would just ask him like what's your
take on 911 like do you have any
conspiracies about it and like the way
that they would answer is the way that
he would vibe with them like if they
said like yeah 911 was for sure like
[__] up and real and all this [__]
you're like all right yeah like I'm not
gonna like like baby you like because he
his job as a quarterback is to try and
bring him up and like teach him and [__]
but if he if they said like conspiracy
he'd be like all right yeah I got your
dog
yeah oh dabs him up so as of right now
he's like I don't know if there's a
tweet out there already because it's
first day of free agency that says that
he's a jet as of right now he's a packer
so the Packers are definitely done with
him I think and I think he'll be a jet
or it's I don't know irony why is he
like
the Ayahuasca the dark room so you're at
the end of your career what's what's
there to why is he it's just I don't
know so extra he definitely believes
like in the other worldly [__] gives him
answers for you know this world this
realm so who gives I don't yeah it's
also like midlife crisis like yeah you
gotta figure some [__] out yeah yeah and
then this dude found Infowars like 20
years too late
we all died in 2012. yeah the moon
landing and everything oh
yeah what do you guys think man take
pretty sick right yeah I think it's
pretty sick I think it's kind of fake
Loki yes right that's my litmus test
social situations
yeah that's cool but like yeah moon
landing was kind of tight huh
God
yeah if they did it you know what I mean
that's what yeah yeah I got you dude
dude is that James Bond on the moon
they're shooting in the same Studio that
day
yeah because it was down here
they were able to do that oh my God bro
holy [__] kids
are you mad and Brady wants to do
no he's coming for your spot
that's fine hit dude I bet you his
stand-up will go crazy like that [__] no
no no no no no no no I'm not saying the
material is going to go crazy I'm saying
like the the I bet you look like a
Beatles Concert yeah it's just gonna be
women yes [__] 25 to 38. he's just
gonna get up there and be like
so I'm here yeah no matter what he says
he goes up there and he goes white
people be like
oh dude I'll find a ticket
my goal for him is to come out of
retirement and play for the Niners oh
wait what this is real no no no there's
like like some conference does he
actually want to be stand up though so
basically you know that movie 80 for
Brady yeah he got so I watched it I
watched a little bit he got so inspired
he wanted to you wanted to go into
comedy a little bit more
uh and so the idea is he won't do us he
won't do stand up but he'll do a roast
where everyone can come out and roast
him oh then he'll hire a bunch of
writers yeah get the feeling of telling
jokes not really the same thing
it kind of is I don't know it's fine I
mean have you seen Eddie for Brady yeah
what did you think of it did you watch
it yet no I mean it's like exactly what
you think it is but it's kind of
charming
it's not that shitty some of the jokes
are actually really funny
it'd be cool as hell I think if why do
you like it so much now I mean I thought
it was unique I I feel the same way well
I watched the trailer and I was like
okay this is [__] ass and then I
watched it and I was like it's kind of
unique like these three these four
ladies who all have won Oscars I'm
pretty sure are all like in their 70s
and 80s well they're doing a comedy
together that never happens he cannot
take you seriously it's kind of cool why
are you being so excited about it
because I literally like just watched it
there's so many other great movies
laughs
hey my bad my bad [__] Cody said he
heard me like it's poorly get on when it
ever happened
hey who Am I who am I is
the Oscars oh my God sorry Cody did you
see the the trailer for The Jennifer
Lawrence movie yes no not good well it
looks good what I feel like me and you
would get along great oh yeah do you
guys want to join Ryan and watch a
kissing movie yeah honestly
we do have similar tastes have you guys
seen RR yet
so [__] good what's that it's a it's
like a Bollywood movie that aired on
Netflix and it's about bro it's about
wait did you guys see the schmungus
thing yeah yeah I did see the smoke I
saw that how funny is that what was that
I think I still don't know the VPN but
for what from where from space bro it's
not funny can you look that up Luke you
didn't see it okay you gotta see this oh
that's weird so you hear Indian and you
think of a VPN all right okay
dude so wait wait it's a Bollywood movie
I know the Bollywood movie is about
Brotherhood I haven't seen a lot it's
about obviously dancing and beautiful
music it's about war it's just insane
it's awesome it's about race
I'll check it out how long is the movie
but you if I watch it you have to watch
80s for Brady
my movies
hell no
ladies but it's hella good it's hella
good yeah everybody's like [__] three
hours yeah I've watched it three times
yeah yeah that's not good wait hold up
man
I just had to say think how cool would
be you walk into an open mic and Tom
Brady's just there that'd be sick like a
bomb ass Open Mic yeah it gets only 15
people there and he's just no he's like
putting in the work like really good
Tommy's like what's up man you gotta
start from the bottom hey man yeah
yeah I think I got three right now he's
last on the lineup too yeah yeah yeah
yeah you're just chilling
gets up for one person he's like
deflate Gates nah
[Music]
the only thing that leaves you deflated
more is my ex-wife
I miss her
where's the light is the light
is the light here shoot me
what is this now
schmungus category it's so funny can you
blow it up yeah whoa
chill man Walid can you blow it up
okay I'm at my girlfriend's house can
someone tell me what these categories
are I hate this guy's voice schmungus
a VPN into what another dimension I
married a schmungus what the hell is
this
what is the schmungus Among Us
schmuckus's Revenge
[Music]
there's no way
I don't like no one knows it's on a
random account
like they don't have any followers yeah
I feel like it's edited yeah it's no it
is but like who like it's it's so well
done like how do you drop that how did
they make like that was like uh Paul
Giamatti or whatever in that one
guy's voice dude who did this oh my God
is this Netflix
I married a schmungus it's a VPN
who's real doesn't it it doesn't it
interface seems hella real much other
dimension